Build the imagination.
That's why when you read sounds of the lambs and you watched a movie,
you got to get all everybody in that room and give them a big hug because they
kept it honest.
They kept it real.
When you read William Blakely's,
the exegesis,
and then the excess is,
has been on for the last two weeks on AMC.
And I've been watching bits and pieces of it and I can't applaud it more,
you know,
it was fucking great.
That movie,
the priest,
that's Jackie Gleason son in law,
is it really?
Yes.
Who's Jason Stoll?
Who's Jason?
Whatever,
his father,
Jason,
whatever it was that he was in sleepers with,
uh,
with,
Brad Pitt Deniro.
He played the newspaper reporter.
That's his fucking father.
But Damian Karras plays the priest.
That's Jackie Gleason,
his son in law.
He married Jackie Gleason,
his daughter.
And it's been funny because last week I was in my office typing and my wife
called,
she goes,
I'm gonna be home in 20 minutes with the baby,
so I don't know what you're doing.
Like,
all right,
so I want it the living room.
And I turned the TV on and just to be out there,
cause I know that you're going to want to watch cartoons or whatever,
and I saw the exorcisms on,
I turned it on and dog it came on when the priest comes to the door,
which if I have a bump into that director,
I will take his dick out and suck it because that's what real directing is he
scheduled without showing you anything.
Yeah.
Remember when the priest comes to the door,
all you see is an image from a priest and you don't want to see what his face
looked like and it scares you.
But when he walks in,
he takes this motherfucker and the guy says to him,
can I get you something?
How was your trip?
Can I get you something?
And he goes,
do you want some coffee?
no,
let's do this.
And this guy's a psychiatrist.
You have to watch the gun.
This guy's a psychiatrist.
Not only is he a priest and he starts dropping and psycho and the priest looks
over and goes,
knock it off.
The devil was cutting,
you know,
tack your psychological like nobody else.
Do not listen to him.
And he just breaks it down.
And then the guy says to him,
do you want to know the three levels of manifestation?
And he looks at them.
He goes,
no,
there's only one saint Ignace,
same dog.
It's just right there.
You're like,
so my daughter walks in,
bots on the five year old,
walks in and she sits on my lap and she's a Bible beater.
I don't know if you know this,
that mercy is a Bible beater.
She loves anything with God.
And you know,
I got a little fucking things she gave me with Jesus.
A fish.
Yeah,
mercy.
My daughter's a Bible beating,
even though she goes to fucking public school,
she'll come home with Tom and they didn't talk about God to that.
So she's watching this whole manifestation of these two priests talking about
God is powerful.
God is going to kill Satan,
Dah,
Dah.
And all of a sudden they walk into the room and she's sitting up and she's like,
Eh,
my daughter it so good.
Like 30 seconds to just look at me and she's just right out of the room like she
doesn't know who Satan is,
nothing.
She just ran out of the room.
This is one of the scariest movies,
one of the finest movies.
She elevates herself.
Calms down.
What about when they,
so they do the first thing they walk out.
And what about when they walked back in and he's a,
he's a doctor so he's checking her heart and she turns into the mother and the
hospital and start saying,
BME,
why you do this to me?
And,
and the priest told him,
don't listen to him.
That the devil's Connie,
you know,
and all of a sudden,
what about when he comes in?
He goes,
father,
how about sparing five science from an all off the bar because the devil start.
I mean Bro,
you have to watch it and while all this is going on,
you have to remember that there's a murder going on because the first night when
she came down,
before the devil came in and some guy was talking,
shit,
I'm not,
fee was talking shit.
A Jewish guy was talking shit about a Nazi or something and she comes down and
peas and says,
you're going to die motherfucker.
She just say gonna die up there to an astronaut,
wasn't it?
Wasn't he an astronaut?
He was something downstairs and she said something like that,
you're going to die up there.
No,
no.
He was downstairs.
They were in the living room and they were singing and it didn't she,
she was talking to a guy who was an astronaut and she just said,
you're going to die.
And then she peed the car pass and then there was a dinner party and then a
couple of nights later they found the guy in the bottom of the stairs,
but it couldn't have been a girl because they twist with his neck all the way
around.
So it had to be a man and that's why you have to watch that movie when the cop
comes to talk to her mother.
I was just famous actress.
The last time I watched it was like five or six years ago.
It's first of all,
it's a deep,
dark moving.
That girl got fucked up doing that movie.
You know,
listen,
how can they make a 12 year old girl just took across my pussy?
I mean,
let's talk about,
she started crossing the push.
He took it out,
grabbed her mother by the ears,
put her in such shock chocolate,
eat me like,
yeah,
all right.
And then picked her up and smacks her and throws her across the fucking room.
She says,
your mother's sucks Cox in the house.
After she told her one breaks,
then you'd do I show that in the movie theater.
Shame on them.
Like if I could sue the union city cinema today,
I was sued because they didn't check my id.
They didn't give a fuck.
They took my $2 and let me,
cause they threw me to the fucking wolf.
But I also saw,
what was her name again?
Linda Blair.
She showed up 20 years later she started hanging out with Rick James.
Um,
she,
she showed up 20 years later.
Richard,
I wonder what Linda Blair is doing today,
but I hope they paid her a lot of money because she never really recovered from
that.
She never really worked after that.
It's tough to get work after you put across from your pussy.
I mean,
as Ginger Lynn,
I,
it's tough to get to commercial for fucking bounce I,
yeah.
Well it's also people never forget you are that person.
Like it's very difficult for people to have a changed perception where she walks
down the stairs.
Yeah.
Backwards.
What about one of the head spins around in front of the priests?
I mean,
it's just too out there for a movie.
They could never,
they think of remaking that every once in a while and they looked at each other.
Look at it.
Okay,
Jesus Christ.
That was a creepy fucking movie.
And you kind of realize that back then there was nothing like this before this
movie.
This movie was so extreme,
like there had been horror movies before,
but it was like Frankenstein or Dracula.
They were kind of scary,
but the warm bloody,
there was nothing like this movie.
This movie was so over the top and people,
a lot of people at the time or like this,
the movie represented something and represented a changing of boundaries that
people,
these young kids,
these people today,
like what the fuck are they doing?
What kind of movies of them?
What is this?
I remember being,
I remember being in Catholic school and they would just piss there with Thomas
not to go see it.
We weren't allowed to go see it out,
bro.
That's,
I was right there when the movie got released and I had to see it and they you,
you can't see it.
Yeah,
right.
You're going to see it blew my fucking,
that's where I saw all rocky,
where everybody was on their feet yelling for rocky.
This is what America was different.
Every body was yelling rocky and they also saw the longest yard daddy original
and Eh,
this was a movie theater that was basically Irish,
Italian.
I'm Cuban,
but they,
they talked,
they yelled at the screen,
you know,
they threw things at the screen and when the fucking longest yard one for
rentals was coming back,
the whole places on their feet.
This is a great movie theater and they let you in that.
Then they played the last movie at 1130 I just thought,
you know how many times I just want to enter the dragon in that,
the late movie,
my mother would let me walk up there cause it was on 48th street and my mother's
ball was on 29th street and she'd go,
go to,
and I saw everything that fist of fury,
the outlaw Josey Wales,
all those fucking movies.
I saw that.
And even when they played,
I just go there as a Spanish kid,
watch it and learn the language and loved it.